こんにちははじめ社長です2024年1月
の13日から1月の14日まで大学入試
大学入学共通テストがありました受験生の
皆様まずは一旦お疲れ様でした共通テスト
の結果を元に自分の行きたい大学の合否が
出る人もいるしその結果を元に2次試験が
ある人もいると思います引き続き頑張ら
なきゃいけない人もいると思うので結果が
どうであれ出てしまった数字は出てしまっ
た数字です何も考えなくていいです
ただただそのまま
勉強頑張ってくださいちなみに共通テスト
とは何かこれ多分ね子供たちあと学生の皆
さん高校卒業してから大学行きたいよって
思ってる人は多分受けるべくテストだと
思います大学入学共通テストとは大学に
入学を志願するものの高等学校高校におけ
る基礎的な学習の達成の程度を判定する
ことを目的とされたテストでま大学教育
大学に行くにあたってふさわしい能力とか
適性があるかどうかを多面的総合的に評価
判定するテストのことです俺の時代はね
センター試験とも言われていたんですけど
もほぼ同じ仕組みかな俺もいつ受けたん
だっけ10年以上前だなセンター試験共通
です受けましたがもうめっちゃ緊張しまし
たねちなみに俺は超滑りましたよそり
150点点数が下がってしまったという
もう大失敗したんですけどもそれでも元気
に生きてますていう共通テストっていうの
があるんですけども今年2024年の共通
テストなんか
英語がめちゃくちゃ難しかったと話題に
なっていますネットとか見たけど本当に
そっぽいななんかえぐかったらしいですよ
えニュースでも英語の時間が足りないとか
センター試験俺が受けてた時代より文章料
が1.8倍約2倍の2倍の長文になってる
のか過去位置難しいという話も東大生の
解説によると英語過去位難しいとも言われ
てるらしいですそんな難かったんですか
今年のなんか今年の共通デストの英語が
もうめちゃくちゃ難しいって言われてるん
ですけれどもなるほどやってみましょうと
いうわけで今日の動画は2024年の共通
テスト英語はめ社長実際にやってみたいと
思います本物の準備しましたちなみにまだ
何も見てないし回答も一切見てません本当
に何も知らない状態ですいやもう受験生の
現役を知りづいてかなり10年以上経って
ますであのYouTubeのことしか考え
ずに10年ぐらい生きてるのであのほぼ
バカですいかに毎日バカなことを考えるか
みたいな仕事してるのでこのバカがあさん
のバカYouTuberが2024年の
めちゃくちゃ難しいと言われている共通
テストの英語を受けると果たして何点に
なるのか今日はちょっとやってみたいと
思いますちなみにバカバカ言ってますけど
も私はめ社長国立大学国公立大学の教育学
部出身ですそれも専門科目英語ですそれ
だけ言っとくわあと大学在籍中にイギリス
に半年留学してましたとだけ言っておき
ましょうあハードル上がったハードル
上がったけど一応英語は全科目の中では
得意な方でしたちょっと本当にマジでバカ
になっちゃってるんで果たしてそんな難し
いって言われてるとなんかやってみたく
なったので何点取れるのか今から実際に
ちゃんと時間も測ってやってみたいと思い
ますえ低い点数でも馬鹿にしないで
くださいなったらスタートしましょう
リーディングとリスニング両方やります
共通テスト英語の試験時間と配点なんです
けどリーディング読むのが80分で
リスニングが60分の合計140分140
分2時間以上そんな長いっけとりあえず
リーディングが80分リスニングが60分
となってますリーディングが100点満点
リスニングが100点満点のそれぞれ
100点合計が200点満点200点中何
点取れるかってとこですね80分ってこと
は1時からスタートすると2時20分まで
ですね1時になってから2時20分まで
リーディングしますやばいマジ懐かしい
やばい本当にやばいマジで何もわからん
可能な限り頑張ってみたいと思いますただ
共通テストってマークシート式だったはず
なのよね南択のうちからどれかを当て
るっていうのもあるのでワン
チャン運運で当たる可能性もわずかながら
にあるというテストになってますやばい
もう始まるよもう始まる321あスタート
スタートですお願いしますすじゃこっから
本気でいき
ます
うわあ
むつオッケーオッケーオッケー
オッケー
きつ多い
なあ
[音楽]
レフこれ1234でいいの
か1234でいいのかこれ1234でいい
のか
怖い1234でいいの
か
そんないっ
オ頭に入っ
た長こんなに長いん
だこれむずい
[音楽]
わみんな愚痴ばっかりやなこのきすぎ良く
ない
と
オケーやばいあと10
分
げえむだけどこれ
やばいで
やばい終わらん終わらん終わらん適当に
行こう適当にやばい終わるやばいや終わる
終わる終わる
終わる
やばい本当にやばい本当に
やばい
終いやっば80分終わりました第6問まで
あるんですけど6問まで行けませんでした
5まではできたんですけど僕もう全部適当
に何も見ずにマークしまくりまし
たやばすぎるはい続いてリスニング行き
ますリスニングもねなんかもうネットで
問題が出てるのでこれ見ながら答えていき
ます音声もねYouTubeにあったんだ
よなを始めますああるわこの試験ではっき
[音楽]
ますあもう始まる
やこいつペン忘れたなこのレベルなら
行ける
ぞちょっと待ってい問題がなくなりまし
た
[音楽]
ちょろ
あれちょちょっと待ってくださいね俺の
問題が真っ白なん
です
では始めますちょっと待って待て真っ白な
ね止めます家でやるもんじゃないな
ちゃんと問題用紙準備してやるべきですね
家だとなんかむずい
わこれで問題を聞く部分は終わりですじゃ
ねこの後は監督者の回答やめのがあるので
回答を続けることができ終わりました
きつかっ
たはいえっとリスニング全部回答終わり
ましたので答え合わせしていきたいと思い
ます一応時間内にやりましたしあのどこに
もちゃんあのカンニングしてませんまに
受けたんですけどリーディングちょっと
不安だな早速答え合わせしていきたいと
思いますはいというわけで早速答え合わせ
していきたいと思いますなんかね体感え
リーディングはマジでやばいです間に合う
気がしなかった俺あの長文はちょっと自信
があっであ現役の時はね今全然早くないん
ですけど長文読むのがめちゃくちゃ早い
自信があってなんかこういう感じ
で見えるかななんか分にめちゃくちゃ
スラッシュ入れまくるんですよスラッシュ
引いてなんか全部小さい分ごとに区切って
それは丸ことどういう意味が理解するって
いう作戦はめにスラッシュ戦法って言っ
てるんですけどでなんか日本語に訳さない
ようにしてます問題は英語で来るから
なんか日本語に訳してる時間もったいない
から英語を英語のまま理解するって戦法で
昔やっててなんか塾で習ったやつなんです
けど小さいセンテンスに区切てそれを
読み解いていくっていう作戦でやってまし
たあとね長文でたくさんあるんですけども
いらない単語たくさんあるんですよZとか
ウッチとか意味をなさない言葉結構
たくさんあるんでそれをもう一瞬で消し去
るっていうごめんなさいねあの教育学部
英語でしてちょっとこういうの好きだった
んですよね今は全然ダメですけどこんな
めちゃくちゃ解説性超低かったらどう
しよう英語のリーディング本当ごめん
なさい間に合わなかったので自信がない
ですじゃあちょっと答え合わせしていき
たいと思いますいや怖えこれで全てが
決まるのか1問目が
42問目が1
おえ3問目が4おお5問目が3あれあれ
あれえええええええ元気元気元気9が
410が2えええ今んとこ全部あってんだ
けどおええすごい
すごい来てる来てる来てるよしよしよしよ
よしよしあよしよしえすごいいい感じです
3940は62全然違うやん
けやばいこっからも適当ですね間に合わ
なくて全部適当にやったやつです43が
やばいおいおいあやばい
わえリーディング終わりまし
た多分第6問0点だなこれ見てきましょう
かあの時間かけすぎましたね完全に現役の
感覚を忘れてるあの英語はできるんですよ
ある程度はここら辺しっかりバチバチに
答えてったんですけどでここもねちゃんと
時間かけて点は取れたもの
のこっからですここより以降がもう時間
なくて適当にやりましたはいバツバツバツ
バツバツバツバツバツもう勘で書いたらも
全部マシと外れ最後にこんなどでかい文章
あるの知らなかったからさもう最悪だよ
やらかしましたちなみにえ100点中第6
問の配点が24点なので俺ここで24点
マイナスは確定
ですそっちからやればよかったこんな配転
でかいんだったら絶対第6問からやるべき
だわこれこれ問題解く順番とかも大事なん
すよね絶対6からやるべきだったよこれ
集計しますまず24マイナス確定でしょ
[音楽]
えぐ
リーディング
中69点でし
たくそミスったね第6問が24点配点とは
思わなかったな問題の解き方の順番とかが
あるんですよねこれはも俺のミスですただ
第6問以外ほぼ合ってたからよしよそれ
以外は何何もミスったんだろう3問ぐらい
ミスったかないやこれ時間があればどれ
ぐらい取れたかやってみたかったなただ
やっぱ時間内にやるっていうのが共通
テストなのでこれは本当に俺のスピード
不足ですね続いてリスニング調べます
リスニングでもそんなむくなかった気がし
たいはいはいはいはい
[音楽]
はい241おお
お結構結構結構結構きてる1516何6点
ミスのリスニング100点中2問ミス94
点でし
たあのね
正直余裕でしたなんだろう人生経験なのか
オーストラリア行ったり海外行くことも
増えたりなんか英語の映画とかもよく見
てるからなんか耳はね現役の時より良く
なってる気がするはいえバカ
YouTuberはじめ社長の共通テスト
英語の点数リーディング69点リスニング
94点合わせて163点でし
た
降参の時もこんな点数だった気がするな
現金の時も160ちょいだった気がするな
8割ぐらいでした
え頑張ったくないめちゃ頑張った方な気が
するけどもうリーディングがさ英語の文章
量がめちゃくちゃえぐかった気がします
多分受験生のみんなも時間かければ解け
るっていう難易度の問題だったんでしょう
けどあまりに英語の文章量が多すぎて
間に合わないっていう人がが多発したのか
なっていう印象は受けましたいやあのそれ
より思ってより点数取れてちょっとほっと
してますこれマジでなんか5割も取れて
なかったらえ本当に教育学部ってなりそう
だったのでちょメズ保たれてよかったです
いや受験生の皆さんそうねでもみんなが
難しいって言ってるってことはおそらく
平均っても下がりますし難しいテスト何か
してる時って全員が低くなるのでそんなに
気にしなくてもいい気もします大丈夫
難しい問題はみんなも難しいから点数も
下がる俺大学受験多分人生で1番命をかけ
てた時期で降参の時のバスケブに対して
から毎日勉強しかしてなくて勉強以外寝る
と旅以外しない生活を半年ぐらい続けたの
かな絶対夜10時半に寝て朝4時半に
起きる4時半から勉強して学校行って学校
終わってから図書館で深夜まで勉強して夜
10時に寝るこの生活をずっと繰り返して
バカだったんですけどなんとかそれで一応
国立大学には受かったような人間なんです
けど大変よね本当に受験は自分との戦いだ
と思ってます心が負けるか負けないか大学
受験の終わり頃もう限界すぎて人麻心出て
ましたもん体に結果がどうであれ何かにま
今回は勉強っていうものですけど何かに
一生懸命取り組めたあなたのその姿勢その
心の強さは絶対君を人間として強くするし
この先の人生の影のない経験になると思い
ます苦労したたから分かるんですけど本当
に辛かったりきつかったり周りが気になる
瞬間あると思うんですけども言勉強最後
まで頑張ってくださいはめ社長は応援して
ます
とりあえず俺のメは保たれ
[音楽]
た
お